un boléro pour lancer la guinguette mort
pas yens les seniors de la ville ont
enflammé la piste installée pour
l'occasion dans la cour du centre de
loisirs primaire de maurepas village
un après midi de danse et de
convivialité je n'ai pas dansé d'abord
parce que c'est passionnant de danse et
parce que on connaît très bien le
village est en fait j'ai toujours
parfait jeune voisine gêné voisins j'ai
des belles dames c'est bien les danses
un petit peu seul parce que mon écoute
n'aime pas danser donc je crois que je
vais pas être accompagnées donc je vais
danser sur un petit peu folklore on se
retrouve tous ensemble ceux qui partent
en vacances on reparle de nos vacances
des petites anecdotes qu'on a eu des
échanges pendant le déjeuner au menu
merguez ou en nouilles est accompagné de
frites ou de taboulé une première pour
la ville de merpins
l'objectif c'est toujours dans l'esprit
est toujours sur la même ligne projet
intergénérationnel et bling avec les
seniors c'est à dire que au tout au long
de l'après midi va y avoir des master
class avec des jeunes du mille club pour
danser avec nous est née cette fête
permet de rentrer dans la période
estivale avant de partir en vacances
pour certains mort d'asia
[Musique]